puisque cette journée est consacré au
défilé c'est la date idéale pour vous
parler des majorettes dans le nord pas
de calais un photographe vient de
publier un livre qui leur est
entièrement consacré apparu dans les
années 60 initiée par les américains est
les compagnies de majorettes sont
toujours très présente dans cette région
de france soir muller caroline boîte
grand-fort-philippe nord pas de calais
6078 habitants et 28 majorelle
tout ce qui est cher et brillant tout ce
qui brille leur est cher par fanfaronner
non mais parade est de 4 à 23 ans devant
une foule la plume bien ou emberlificoté
de fil d'or
la bottine claquant sur le bitume acier
et les paupières émeraudes saphir ubi en
mettre plein les mirettes
quand on dit si le côté ferrer que quand
les petits regarde avec des yeux
brillants
c'était les années 60 au défi les cas
qui succédait ces gamines un peu kitsch
armes et d'opérette ou major majorettes
dans le nord les clubs résiste encore
les passer dit on aujourd'hui
ouais le temps a la mémoire courte un an
durant charles fréger à tirer le
portrait de tous les groupes de la
région rémi aujourd'hui en un livre des
poteaux sans un sourire qualifié parfois
de cruelles
les filles se seraient plutôt comme un
album de famille accusé un petit peu de
cynisme avec ses photos non non c'est
pas du cynisme c'est disons que le point
de vue d'abord la majorette ses dires et
vu de paris damas jaurès est un peu
rustique quoi donc
il ya des gens qui pensent que la
majorette sais c'est quelque chose un
peu ringard alors qu'en définitive à mon
avis c'est une vraie scène culture en
soit nous appelons le photographe s'est
plongé dans ce monde à part et exigeant
quatre heures d'entraînement par semaine
15 minutes de corée à manier le bâton
sous la baguette de la présidence
bon vous venez moi j'ai trouvé que
l'alignement au niveau de la fin n'est
pas bon je préviens je veux aucun bateau
par terre et je veux vous donner à fond
on est bien tous d'accord elle qui est
pas d'accord
elle fera sur les six filles et non 5
ont fait leurs classes dans les
majorettes il y à delphine la présidente
tantôt dure souvent miel stéphanie la
capitaine gwendoline aussi la petite
nièce
seule la maman n'a pas eu droit à son
trophée trop petit 10 et on à l'époque
aujourd'hui elle sort à travers vous
avez toujours son cul ouais ouais ouais
j'adore ça j'ai sortait seule marque à
prix majorettes ça ça je suis toujours
chez noa souvent c'est pour un amoureux
que l'on remise sa passion lui les
chasseurs moi je suis là j'aurai donc
quand j'ai connu je lui ai dit justin tu
me connais je suis majorettes certains
joueurs de me demander de quitter les
majorettes pour toi
charles l'avait promis il est revenu
photographier le tout nouveau costume
un de plus dans cette histoire aigre
douce un compte de princesse à la robe
de diamants au royaume de
grand-fort-philippe 6078 habitants